mental toughness for me is
you see only good in everything even if
something catastrophic happens you only
see the good
because there is good in all bad events
there is some good
if tomorrow a doctor tells you you're
going to die in cancer in six months
well you got to tell yourself
i'm going to live at another level in
these six months because i know these
days are numbered so every day for me is
going to be like a year
every second is going to be like hours
for me because i'm going to appreciate
it that much
there's got to be something positive in
whatever happens
one of my favorite new authors that i'm
reading into now is uh
marcus aurelius and he wrote his
journals
you know during the war with the
germanic tribes he was writing in his
journal and
this was just his own personal journal
wasn't a book and
he was in a situation where he was
leading the softer generation of romans
the romans they haven't gone through war
they're just living through the spoils
of their fathers who went to war
and dominated the world so they weren't
ready to go to war and fight these these
barbarians et cetera and they were more
uh
corrupt and wanted to live the good life
etc and he's writing in this journal and
he's considered one of the great great
five emperors he was one of the
the the best leaders rome ever had and
he was basically saying that he was
saying you have to find
the good in every single bad situation
and this is a guy who is
on the brink of being destroyed by the
germans he eventually
defeated the germanic tribes but it was
almost
lights out for rome at that time and he
was you're reading this journal of his
and his
his thoughts and he's like your thoughts
are what you soak your mind in
the dye you soak your mind in and how
you see the world
all depends on your thoughts because
somebody who sees the positive and
everything
you can't beat him you have to kill him
to beat him because no matter how low
you put him down if there's still a
spark
he still believes he can climb to the
top where somebody sees the negative
and they start to convince themselves
they're lost they're easy to beat they
already beat themselves
i really love that description and and
that's something that my partners
ron mike and i talk a lot about is you
know when you're in business
you learn very quickly that you're
operating without a safety net right so
it can all go away
not only tomorrow it could go away today
right i could walk off the set only to
find out that some catastrophic thing
has happened and now we're out of
business
i mean and that really forces you to
analyze what do i have in my life to
fall back on and you talk a lot about
what fighters that have nothing to fall
back on right i think you quoted don
shula you know and having a three-tier
system of
god family and football that's correct
um and and in
business i find it the same if you if
you don't have something to fall back on
you're going to be in real trouble and
the thing that we
have collectively always focused on is
what you just said which is
the guy that has a spark of hope no
matter how low you take him he believes
in his heart that he can rise back up
and it's interesting because i've never
put that together as being mental
toughness
uh but it's it it's a pretty core
component certainly of
i think it's resiliency it's an
incredibly important core component
because once you're depressed inside
um it becomes a downward spiral of
negativity
you can never let yourself have negative
emotions for
a prolonged period of time and actually
it's a great thing marcus surrealist
also
says that he says whenever you you lose
you're off balance emotionally
see how fast you can bring yourself back
to being positive and make it a game he
says you know like just see how fast
because for him think bad things were
happening every day right you know
literally
every day he was betrayed by his best
friend his wife
left him you know all these he'd bring
him back himself back to
being centered and you know and
this is key because a person like that
will be successful down the line in the
long run
that's the worst person to face if
that's your enemy he's never
no matter what you throw out of him
he'll never go away he'll never quit
he in his mind it's going to work out in
the end
somehow some way and i look around me
all the time and i see people who were
down and out and then came back to make
it they went down and down they came
back to make it like you see that in
corporations you see that individual you
see that in fighters you see that in
actors you see that all across the board
so winners see a bad situation as
temporary
winners see a bad situation as temporary
that's it no matter how down and out you
are
it's temporary